so i'd i'd love for you to to go back
when you
first decided to elevate everyone's
salary to 70
000 which gained you national fame and
accolades
and you took a pay cut personally in
order to
make this 70 thousand 000 salary floor
possible yeah well i had been
indoctrinated in all the things that
you're saying
that we've both been talking about in
terms of kind of the system
and how other companies think about
things the supremacy of shareholders all
those things
but it was going against what i was
actually seeing with my own eyes
and so in 2011 i was really inspired by
an employee who was telling me
she wasn't making enough and she had to
take a second job at mcdonald's to
afford to be able to work at my company
and i'm yeah and i'm like you're like
you're one of our best employees like if
you can't afford to live your life
what does that say about me and so in
2011
at the end of the year we set a goal to
average 15
raises in 2012. and then
that we thought would decrease the
profit we were
looking to rebalance the pie and make it
more fair because that's what we thought
would happen based on
everything that's said out there but our
profit actually went up
so we decided well we'll do it one more
time only in 2013.
and we did it again we exceeded the goal
our profit went up so that was happening
every year and we thought this is the
way to run a business
and in 2015 we did a survey across our
whole company
and people were generally pretty pleased
with how we were structured
but i went on a hike with my friend
valerie who was in the army for 11 years
and she's such a hard worker and such an
amazing person
and she was explaining to me how a 200
rent increase was throwing her entire
life
upside down and i was like that doesn't
make any sense you're one of the best
people i know like how is this possible
that you're not being compensated fairly
and then i learned something very
inconvenient which was a third of my
employees were making less than what
valerie was making at that time
she was making about 40k and our lowest
employees were like 30 or 35.
and it was just it was just
heartbreaking for me
and i've seen like the daniel kahneman
angus eton study about how like
you know wellness increases with income
until it doesn't and i'd read all these
things but
ironically and i'm not proud of this it
took
almost like emotional pers personal
experience where this person that i
genuinely like love and care about and
respect so much
was not being taken care of by our
economy
where i realized i was i had built a
company where i can make decisions
and yet i was just following what
everyone else was doing what was hurting
her
rather than doing what i think any
five-year-old would know would be the
right thing in that situation
well way to channel your inner
five-year-old dan because you then
became a national
hero in some circles my circles
when you said you know what we're gonna
make sure that everyone who works
for this company gets paid seventy
thousand dollars minimum
which happens to track with about the
income level
where money no longer affects happiness
because you would now have enough to
meet your
everyday needs yeah and i i would also
say that like
i i appreciate you saying that i think i
think ideally
we would have a world where i don't get
so much credit for doing this
and i i think i get way too much credit
and it was shocking to me
you know somebody that grew up in idaho
and like getting on the local idaho news
would be like being a celebrity in my
world like let alone like the new york
times and all these other places
um talking to you and i it caused me to
reflect and be like why is this
happening and i don't think it's
happening
because i'm such a great person i think
it's just more cuz everyone else is so
[ __ ] shitty it's an indictment on the
system
it i mean it it is it is funny but it
it's true it's an indictment on the
system that somebody that just does
something very logical
like says hey all of us built this
together shouldn't all of us
at least be able enough to live like a
normal life
that that is so radical and noteworthy
um
it's really shocking to me and i think
uh we should be
somewhat ashamed as a society that
that's where we're at right now
there are certain organizations where i
completely
think they could have done what you've
done like a while ago so
some of these organizations that are now
incredibly
wealthy and valuable and oftentimes the
leader
ends up hoovering up the lion's share of
that value in these situations uh
i can relate to a lot of your story dan
and that but this is one thing i will
suggest
is that your business it was in a
situation where if you invested more in
your people
then it spurred more growth better opera
like better morale better retention
uh more creativity i ran an organization
that was in a similar boat
where if you're a growth company and you
invest in your people
then you end up growing more it's like
this magical relationship
and and i'm proud to say that
you know i uh was following some of your
playbook during that time where
i would pay people uh more
like there was always like a level where
you kind of sensed because you know
you're the ceo of a small business like
you kind of get it
it's like i know i can get you for this
much
but i don't i'm going to pay you a
little more than that because i think
you're going to be
just happier like better more productive
less stressed out more content like i i
also was always like whatever i think i
can get them for like i'm gonna like go
a little bit above that
and it's good for us right if we're like
engaging with them and they're a little
happier a little less stressed out then
we're happier and less stressed out
that's true i i'm wired the same way you
are which is like i want the people
around me to be happy
i want them not to be stressed out about
a 200 rent increase like
you know like i think that would just be
better for us all
now and in my case too i did some things
where uh
and this is one of the joys of being a
small business owner where i was like
you know what like we should all go to
the beach i'm going to rent a house
it's got to be a big house to
accommodate everybody and then be like
everyone little bus
pass to the beach or i want to take
everyone skiing or whatever the heck it
was
those were the days i mean i um still
miss them
like uh my now wife and i were
dating during this time and she also was
like oh i miss those days because
you're like the head of this and uh you
know you're positive you want to look
out for people
i will say i'm sympathetic um to folks
who run
certain types of operations in other
industries where frankly like that
relationship might not
apply where if like you invest more in
your people
like maybe you're in like a no growth
environment you're like kind of managing
now that that's i think most businesses
are in situations where
they would benefit from treating people
better higher morale like higher
contentment
lower turnover like the vast majority of
businesses i believe fall in this camp
uh and i'm i'm happy to say that uh
i think that you and i had similar kinds
of experiences
as the heads of small companies i'll say
though
in our industry if you look at our
competitors
they have uh done massive numbers of
layoffs
they've increased the fees that they
charge to small businesses in opaque
ways that those businesses
can't understand or can't see right away
so they can't be held accountable
very quickly and then there are some
companies that are doing a lot of great
innovation
but those companies are telling their
shareholders that they're gonna turn
around
and flip the switch at some point and
start to charge those customers a lot
more
or like start to figure out how to
control costs in the ways that you're
describing
and i feel like i did get kind of
something wrong in terms of my
expectations over the past six years
and that is i thought you know with all
the hubbub and how
you know kind of how much attention we
were getting if we came out and proved
that this could work
that we would have a lot of people
following suit and we have had you know
dozens of companies follow suit and
maybe some some others in big waves but
like generally the problems gotten worse
and just if i can get up on my soapbox
for two minutes and highlight some of
the success we've had
i mean we've tripled as a company in the
past five and a half years
we have 10x the number of babies being
born at the company per year
like we've had 50 or 60 babies i love
how you have that as a measurement it's
like people are
feeling reproductive we have 10x the
number of first-time homeowners
uh 70 of the people at the company have
gotten out of debt
30 say they've gotten completely out of
debt but 70 percent have paid down debt
and people have between doubled and
tripled their savings for retirement
and i i think there's real implications
here for ubi
because the raise that they got is about
the same raise that a thousand dollars
times two adults in a home would get and
most of the people that work at gravity
there are they are two adult homes so i
think there's implications there
so i thought you know we prove all of
that and you would see this general
macroeconomic trend of people thinking
in this direction
but i think we've actually proven the
opposite and i think just the fact that
the story's still big i think we've
proven that people
aren't going to do it voluntarily more
than anything else because we've
shown it can work we've shown we're like
you know we're still
we're still here like we're i'm not poor
like i'm out surfing and playing music
and you seem very happy and healthy dan
yeah have a great life and yet still
nobody's doing it and so it's really
actually
emboldened my perspective on what you're
doing
because i've realized i'm not the answer
i mean maybe i'm the answer in that i
can be a part of the story and
encouraging people and sharing what i've
learned sharing what i know
but we need to all come together behind
these types of
systemic solutions and we can't keep
glorifying
individual one-offs like me freaking
man i want to give you a hug i would
love a yang hug right now
this guy gives the best hugs for
everybody else wow that's so kind of you
you do uh because what what you just
said is so important
where there there was like a period and
i spent uh
you know seven years or so trying to
make something positive happen with
venture for american entrepreneurship
and i thought something similar was like
if i could just show people
that helping these small businesses grow
is just a better path
than heading to the you know
billion dollar bank or the you know
consulting company or whatever the heck
then we could really start to fix things
and incredibly proud of everything that
venture of america continues to do
but i started realizing that the
black hole's gravity field at this point
is way way too strong
and that the software of
our economy that so many people have
internalized that you know we're all
economic inputs and that if you're a
company you have to try and like get it
down to the very last
like you know penny what you can get
away with
that as soon as you get yeah and as soon
as you can throw someone overboard you
definitely should throw them over but
like all of these things
are so deeply entrenched uh not
just in the operations of these
companies
but in our society in people's minds
that i realized that we actually need to
rewrite the rules of the economy
um both from the ground up and the top
down simultaneously but the top down
component
required control of the government and
then i was like well how do you control
the government and then it's like
run for president and win and have the
movement the revolution was like
and and that most people watching this
know
would have been a highly irrational
ambition circa 2018
when you know andrew yang was an
anonymous um entrepreneur
uh but it's born of the same kind of arc
that you went through dan because
you think okay if i can demonstrate this
works then everyone will be like well it
works let's all treat our people better
and then when you're like huh people
really won't treat
like their employees better unless they
get dragged to it kicking and screaming
and the only way to drag them to a
kicking and screaming would be to to
actually get a hold of government and
change some rules
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]
you